strowman will start tonight in game two
of this series last time out in miami
marcus gave up just one run he pitched
into the seventh but the mets lost the
game three to two there's nolan aronado
one for five last night drove in a run
and he gets aronado two on the inning
three strikeouts in that first inning
for strowman wrapped around a walk to
goldschmidt that's come to back with no
score uh woodford's not again not a
dominator he's not going to be out there
throwing 94 95 miles an hour on average
uh the four seamer sits at 92.
bordeaux's got 12 homers this year he's
driven in 46. cardinals middle infield
is back marinado is even between second
and third
good four bloops one to shallow left
that's going to fall for a base hit the
yards in to score in the midst of the
early lead three straight hits conforto
dunks one at the left and it's one
nothing new york there's javi baez with
the lindor at third and two out
and he tries to bart and woodford can't
catch it and that'll bring it a run and
it's two nothing new york
the magic of javi baez
a two out bunt for a base hit woodford
couldn't catch it cleanly and lindor
comes home to score to make it two
nothing here's jeff mcneill mcneal was
over four two strikeouts last night the
pitch to him a swing and there's a
ground ball up the middle diving play by
tommy edmond throwing to second to get
the out
out is baez moving into second
tommy edmond with a sensational play up
the middle to end the met's first inning
now tyler o'neill bats
o'neal base hit into center field goldie
will score
back-to-back hits for the cardinals
and that cuts the mets lead to two to
one rbi number 57 for tyler o'neill
arenado at the plate struck out his
first time up
that's ripped caught by vr throwback to
first and
o'neil able to get back safely
and pull it off the mount of varnado for
the first down and a good opportunity to
tie it here for dylan carlson the 1-0
pitch
to carlson is hit high and deep to right
field back as the right fielder he
catches it but tagging at third and
scoring is tyler o'neil sacrifice flying
an rbi for dylan carlson and we are tied
at two
harrison bader do up here with molina at
third sosa at second base
vader hits one on the ground vr's got it
and the throw is true to end the inning
but the cardinals tie it
rbis by o'neal and carlson to tie it up
2-2 in the fourth
tyler o'neill is the batter rbi single
little run scored his last time
and some cardinals tied at two top of
the fifth
o2 to o'neal
on the inside corner
so strowman picks up his seventh
strikeout and works around a hit in the
fifth halfway through tied at two door
at a base hit to center field and score
to run in the first flight out to the
warning track and left in the
third sails over molina to the backstop
and that'll move the runners up
first curveball from paul stelion and it
never broke
francisco watches low for ball four
quiten is bad for lindor it winds up
being the third straight walk for ponce
de leon to load the bases and that's
going to be the last pitch that he
throws
opportunity for michael conforto with
the bases loaded and one out
and he lifts that one out to left
tacking it third is strowman o'neal
catches it back on his heels and
strowman scores easily to give the mets
the lead
sacrifice fly to for conforto to give
the mets
the edge three to two in the fifth
second rbi of the night for conforto
beat alonso twice has grounded in to six
four three double plays
a look to second
the one-two pitch swing and a miss
alonso strikes out on a high pitch so
the mets got one out of a bases walk
situation
haunts de leon walk three and he's
charged with a run
this was after
the inning was over letting him have it
oh boy let him have it
and
bench coach oliver marmol had to get
between the veteran cat boys young
charge that's heated
now dylan carlson the batter switch
hitter batting left sacrifice fly
his last time
and he gets carlson on the half swing
to retire the side
eight strikeouts for strowman one shy of
his season high 3-2 met to the sixth so
davis will bat in the ninth spot we saw
him as a pinch hitter here last night he
got a hit and the first pitch is hit
high in the air to center field backing
up his baiter he's at the track he jumps
and makes the play a half jump up
against the wall and jd davis hit that
about as far as you can hit it without
it being a home run
so tyler o'neil will bat with a chance
of giving the cardinals a lead with one
swing of the bet
o'neill with a drive
in a deep center and gone
tyler o'neal
launched it to center and the redbirds
have delayed in new york
number 26
for tyler o'neill
and he's driven in three of the four
tonight
so now two out and edmundo sosa comes up
again the 3-2
rounded to third short hop by vr
and he throws out sosa to win the unit
two outs
now goldschmidt will bend
and goldsmith pops one up alonzo should
have a play
and that retires the side and the mets
will have a chance in the bottom of the
ninth trailing by one
all right here we go folks
last chance gotta have it
aviva's will lead off
ice has been on base three times tonight
with a single and two walks
and bias drives one deep left field
toward the wall and o'neill jumps he
can't get it it's a home run to tie the
game
javi fires on the first pitch in the
bottom of the ninth gets the mets even
his 31st home run of the year his ninth
is a met
el mondo ties it up for the bottom of
the ninth
mcneil a force play ground ball a pop-up
and a double play ball
the one
mcneal pops it up left side
orinato over and has it
nolan orinato
reaching into the st louis dugout and
comes up with the first out here in the
bottom of the ninth
embry has not generated a ground ball
double play this season
molina's one for three tonight reached
on catcher's interferences last time up
and molina hits it back to hembree
out at second bias to first double play
side retired
first ground ball double play henry's
gotten all season and he gets it at a
huge spot in the 10th inning and now the
mets will have the free runner with a
chance to win it on the bottom now
lindor on base twice with a single and a
walk runners at first and third one out
and the pitch to lindor is grounded to
the right side goldie steps on the bag
and now they got a bit of run down
between the third and home yachty
chasing him back they tag him out
and it's a double play
oh my goodness what a play by
goldschmidt again at mundo sosa all for
four sosa base head and the left yachty
will score and the cardinals have a 5-4
lead here in the 11th now kisner's
looking to get the ball in the air
kissner up the middle base hit
one run is in here comes another the
throw not in time andrew kesner off the
bench drives in two
and they'll get goldsmith to the plate
with two men on
goldschmidt grounds one in the hole
chance for two baes with the turn six
four three double play ends the inning
alonzo trying to break an over 20 streak
alonzo drives one out to right
but rondon going back
alonso pulls into second base with an
rbi double so now pilar who has been uh
the big extra inning back for the mets
and he taps it slowly tough play for kim
he turns and fires off the bag a run
comes in
seven to six
he had him the mets are alive
the tying run is at second base now
mcneil
the winning run at first base in polar
with albert almora jr coming up to bat
and the 3-2
is a ground ball tommy edmond has it the
cardinals win it
in a year that at times has been defined
by heartbreak
and late inning losses for the cardinals
not tonight 7-6 the final in 11
and on september 14th
your saint louis cardinals have the
second
wild card spot in the national league
what a game
you